[Music]
your wonderful girlfriend is backstage
yes yes yeah I've never started out
talk-show like that just me pointing out
who's with you yeah he's not a good
thing to do to bring your girlfriend
backstage for me to open with that
question it's your show you told me
backstage she thinks you're good at
everything she does and she gives me
this false sense of myself like I go out
into the world thinking I am fantastic
like she's like you are an amazing actor
you I do here's the thing you don't know
about me unless you do and I don't know
how you would but I do a lot of
characters and voices but I only do it
like with friends or somebody I'm dating
like yeah we have that dynamic in the
love bubble yeah I understand and I am
Telling You in the love bubble
I I play everyone and and so I go out
into the world and I will tell people
I'm like yeah my girlfriend thinks I'm
really talented at acting or at voices
yeah and then I shared that with my
friends on my podcast professor
blast-off and they were like oh let's
hear it and I did a voice and everybody
was just looking at me I know exactly
what you mean what voice was it you want
me to do it on television
is this yeah is it this is part of my
love bubble yeah
this show is definitely in the love
bubble it's going to be okay so whatever
it is we'll we're here with you all
right well I was I can't believe I'm
gonna do this but I was I I I tore a lot
and so we had been talking about how in
you know certain people do Baby Talk yes
and not huge fans of it and so then it
became a joke and so now we jokingly do
this weird baby talk from time to time
and I was packing to go out of town and
I said I said I can't believe I'm doing
this
[Applause]
[Applause]
now it's your hand over your mouth
because you can't believe how talented I
am I know exactly where you're at I've
done that in relationships before where
she's like wait I'm getting the feeling
you're not thinking I'm really talented
cuz you're saying I understand what's
happened here that's the tone not like
oh my god you have a huge future in
voiceover as an infant maybe in a horror
film where she's like back to the corner
and
I do want to do it with you I shouldn't
[ __ ] on it it looked like a fun does it
take that's tonight
like James Lipton can I talk to
terrifying toddler I understand you're
packing for a trip any toiletries I
haven't worked that part out yet it's
fantastic it's an in love bit that's the
phenomenon I know and she gives me this
weird confidence and then I go and I do
it on TV and then you go it's an in love
thing but don't you know that you're in
the Club Med and I'm on the outskirts
where the beaches aren't white and I'm
just like so it's fun in there you're
playing the steel drums there's a crab
that serves you cooked crap so you're
you're dancing around there while I'm
folding up checkered shirts going yeah
yeah yeah and you're like sure looks fun
in there and I'm the lonely guy on the
beach with a metal detector are going
maybe there's something buried that
likes my silly voices something this is
the saddest comedy set
[Applause]
when you were packing your little
suitcase were you going to Europe they
told me you just went to Europe
did they I don't know because she came
with me to Europe the character or your
girlfriend my girlfriend and I think the
character showed up a couple times to
the character I'm just plugging into
your joy and it's making me happy
[Music]